[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Applications that
help us reduce the repetitive
tasks make us more productive,
but building them
is hard since it
stitches a lot of different
applications together.
To explore one such
application, I've
invited David Ting, Senior
Vice President of Engineering
at Nylas, a company that's
revolutionizing the workflow
automation by collecting data
from multiple applications,
compiling those insights,
and then creating
an end-to-end
automation workflow.
Hi, David.
Welcome to the show.
DAVID TING: Hi, Priyanka.
Thank you for having me.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: I am
so excited to have you
on the show.
Tell us a little bit
about you and Nylas.
DAVID TING: I am the
SVP of Engineering,
and I'm responsible
for Nylas's product
and technical execution.
Nylas's mission is to make
the world more productive,
and we built up a very
scalable and secure platform
to handle communication data
driving business process
automation.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: OK, so
how does it matter to me,
you, as end users?
DAVID TING: If there are
enough developers that
write all the
applications you need
to automate and
streamlined workflow,
the world would be
much different today.
Why do I have to enter
receipts for expenses?
Why is it so hard to juggle
my calendar when I just
need two hours of focus time?
Building applications to
reduce repetitive tasks
are really hard,
and Nylas's mission
is to make it easier for you
to build high-RI application
and make you a
star in your work.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Wow, productivity
sounds really cool,
and yes, I do not
want to upload my
receipts into a system.
It should just
happen automatically.
How does this actually work?
DAVID TING: So we
capture real-time data
from service providers such
as Gmail, Microsoft, IMAP.
We have data pipelines
power ML models
behind the scene to create
intelligent data objects.
Data from these insights
trigger programmable workflows.
And the challenge is
building up a distributed
real-time architecture for
the billions of messages
that we receive each day and
keep the end-to-end latency
low and predictable.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
All right, so now
that we have put the customer
expectation in perspective,
and now that we know how
Nylas gathers the data
and creates these insights,
what are the technical drivers
for working with Google Cloud?
DAVID TING: We came to
Google with what we viewed
as a very challenging mission.
We have a large
enterprise customer
in the financial services
space with very strict security
requirements.
PII can not be
stored persistently,
and the lifetime of
each server needs
to be short to avoid
potential in-memory hacks.
This was a great reason
for us to rethink the Nylas
architecture.
The legacy Nylas architecture
was built with Python flasks
on top of AWS.
It was difficult and
very costly to scale,
and the end-to-end
performance is unreliable.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Interesting.
Why was it so costly to scale?
DAVID TING: Nylas processes over
20 terabytes of data every day,
and the high volume
of read and writes
are mainly hitting against
hundreds of MySQL shards.
The workload is partitioned
as email accounts
across a farm with
a static assignment.
Because volume of the emails is
unpredictable for each account,
there are many hotspots that
emerge throughout the day,
causing high variability in
latency and, in severe cases,
reliability issues.
In order to address this, we
had to overprovision the system
by a good margin in order to
keep that latency in control.
Based on extensive load
testing, with the same traffic
load, whenever we double the
infrastructure footprint,
we can lower the
P90 latency in half.
And at our current scale,
doubling our footprint,
it really means a million
dollars in cloud cost,
so that's not a
sustainable strategy.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Wow,
that is a lot of money.
All right, so three
big major issues
that you set out to solve--
the security, scalability,
performance, and, obviously,
cost.
So why did you
pick Google Cloud?
DAVID TING: In my
mind, Google Cloud
has the best
distributed technology
and has been a true engineering
partner throughout the journey.
The security, scalability,
and stability of the platform
is second to none.
GKE is currently the best
option out of any cloud provider
to run Kubernetes workload
securely at scale,
and one of the most performant
data stores in Spanner.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: So now I want
to get into my favorite part,
which is the architecture.
How did you approach
it, what was it like,
and how is it going?
DAVID TING: We were
able to transition
to a brand new
architecture and achieve
a huge ROI for the project.
The big bets of using GKE
to handle the container
orchestration, Pub/Sub
for message bus,
and Spanner for relational data
store has paid off handsomely.
We went live on June
4, and we really
knocked it out of the park.
Everything has been
scaling effectively.
For example, when
an application has
performed over 1 billion
transactions in less than a
month--
and then, this is
on top of Spanner--
what I cannot believe is
that the latency is actually
controlled very well,
to 7 milliseconds.
And this really speaks
volumes to the robustness
of GCP services.
By working closely with
the GCP Account Team
and a great partner in Bespin.
We're able to address most of
the issues before the launch.
So our customer's
QA team went in
and tested our
initial prototype.
They found zero issues.
And we spent the rest of the
time optimizing the workload
as we scale on GCP.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Great!
Well, how did you go
from-- you mentioned
that you went from a
Python-based application to Go.
You did an entire rewrite.
How did you do that?
And moving from virtual
machine instances on EC2
to GKE, how did
that process happen?
DAVID TING: As part of the
re-imagination exercise,
we had to take some big bets.
And what we did was
we actually decided
to rewrite our services
in Go, because we
believe that there's a 10x
throughput improvement when
we do this.
The second part is
moving, basically,
the orchestration here from
Cloud-specific and an AWS
autoscaler group.
We basically want to
go with the industry
standard in GKE or Kubernetes.
So we used GKE to
orchestrate the containers,
and do to the
security requirements,
the nodes have to be
cycled very quickly.
So we're able to take
advantage of the fact
that we can have up to 15,000
nodes in a Kubernetes cluster
on GKE.
And that's actually something
that other cloud providers
don't provide.
In addition, we're
also using gVisor
to run the containers to
create a strong isolation
between the application
and the operating system.
This helps us to lock down the
host memory and storage access
and enforce least permission
principle at the operating
system level.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Earlier,
you mentioned 20-plus terabytes
of data being processed in
hundreds of MySQL shards--
which, obviously,
wasn't really efficient
and was also extremely costly.
How did you solve that as you
re-imagined this architecture
in Google Cloud?
DAVID TING: We
made some big bets.
And so we used Spanner as
the relational data store
to keep states for
the application
and also store the keys for
each one of the accounts
we need to connect to.
So fast read and write
access performance
is extremely critical for
a large number of calls.
We need the consistent
high performance
to have predictable
end-to-end latency.
And that actually has
paid off by betting on--
running on GCP services
versus doing it ourselves.
Lastly, Nylas does
not have to hold PII.
So this information is pushed so
that once our customers receive
it, we purge the information
from our store for security
reasons.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
For communication
between those microservices,
you used Pub/Sub.
Can we talk a little
bit about why and how
Pub/Sub has been helpful?
DAVID TING: Yes, so we went from
a very database-centric design
to an event-centric design.
So for us, the message bus
is the key and the heart
of our whole design.
So we chose Google Pub/Sub for
an event-driven microservices
architecture.
And just as a comparison, in
the AWS world and the legacy
architecture,
because it's actually
more of a data-driven
architecture,
the data is written into Dynamo.
Then, it gets converted
by a lambda function,
and then it goes to
Kinesis events stream.
So in Google Cloud, we
want to simplify this.
So we want it event first.
And so we rewrote it
directly on Google Pub/Sub.
So it actually puts a lot
of strain on the system,
so there's a lot of trust that
we have in how this scales
and how it's going to perform
reliably and consistently.
And we were very happy with the
experience on Google Pub/Sub,
where the performance
latency is minimal,
even when we have to
burst to tens of thousands
of writes per second.
So you can even
think about Event Bus
to basically be like
a data store for us,
because it is that reliable
and scalable for us.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yeah,
that is amazing to hear.
What are some of the
benefits that you've
achieved after migrating
to Google Cloud?
DAVID TING: This cannot happen
without exceptional service,
so we're very happy with
everyone we've worked with
at GCP.
We were able to get over 30
times the throughput per node
after the rewrite in
Go, and in addition,
the elasticity of the
architecture has been amazing.
It's reliable.
Latency doesn't go down.
Performance is actually
stable as we actually
have traffic spike.
It's just outright
amazing when you
work with the
high-scale architecture.
Our customer has been
migrating their entire user
base onto Nylas in
June, and the process
has been extremely smooth.
And in addition, during
Amazon Prime Day,
where just a lot of bursts
in e-commerce transaction
come in within the minute,
we saw that a number of nodes
went from a handful
to tens of thousands
of nodes within a few minutes.
And we're able to handle
the peak consistently,
and the P90 performance
actually was stable,
even with those spikes.
And it's just really
amazing to think back,
and we were able to
accomplish out all
of that in just three months.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Wow, three
months is a pretty impressive
timeline for a migration this
big where you had to rewrite
from one language to another--
in this case, Python to Go--
and then also learning
all these new tools--
GKE, Spanner, and Pub/Sub.
And I'm sure it was a
very massive team effort.
What was your
experience like working
with the Google team and
the partner in this process?
DAVID TING: I want to first
thank the Nylas engineering
team.
I have not worked
with a group that
is as talented and as dedicated
in their work in my career.
Secondly, I would like to thank
our partner, GCP and Bespin
for making this happen.
We're able to work as one
team over emails in Slack
and resolve issues in real time.
Most companies would
need at least one
year to pull off an
architectural overhaul
of this order of magnitude.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: This
is absolutely phenomenal--
the speed, the collaboration.
What is the road ahead?
What does future
technical enhancements
look like for your architecture?
DAVID TING: With the
success we experienced,
we want to shoot bigger.
So we had the confidence to
handle more challenges ahead
and we're looking
to work with GCP
on advanced AI/ML
use cases where
we're extracting valuable
insight contained
within communication channels
while automating workflows
for our clients.
Our customers have planned
to increase their usage
several orders of
magnitude, and they're
pushing with all
their marketing power
to reach more users
and customers.
And, of course, we have many
more mega clients waiting
in our pipeline, and we have the
confidence with the partnership
that we have to basically take
on more of them concurrently.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Well, all
that sounds really exciting,
and I wish you and
the team good luck
in implementing some
of those enhancements.
Thanks, David, for
diving into the details
of this incredible journey
and architecture with me.
DAVID TING: Well, thank
you for the opportunity
to share our
experience at Nylas.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Well, we just saw
how Nylas migrated to
GKE, Pub/Sub, and Spanner
to achieve the performance,
scalability, and security goals
while keeping the
costs in check.
If you want to learn more, check
out the blog I've linked below.
And if you've got any topic
ideas for upcoming customer
stories, put them in
the comments below,
and I will find that use
case and bring it to you.
Bye!